[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
you like like avengers and [ __ ] like you
like aquaman i like it when they bring
in the hulk
yeah i like the hulk
i didn't watch aquaman because i'm not
i'm not watching any movie with amber
heard in
it tell you what i am watching is the
trial i do it's the best reality show of
all time i think i need to spark a joint
if we're going to talk about the truck
do it bro because i can't get enough of
it it's literally it's amazing it's
fantastic sorry i was almost late i was
jerking off to the uh amber heard trial
holy [ __ ]
yeah that is a hot trial huh
hot tamale holy hell
amber heard she's a real kook that turns
me on you know she should date as a band
margera i think they would go well
together huh that'd be a fun fun thing
to watch all right you know chris brown
is watching that trial going i would
have knocked this out years ago
she's a what is that
misspelt
it's is
that's what she is she's like that
she just walks around and she eats damn
that's all she does she's like the soul
out your body suck it right out dude
[ __ ] acted acted like giant dev
had a chance
his wife should apologize to him
johnny depp's wife should apologize
because he was going up against a force
that they're they cannot be reckoned
with
i don't understand one day his son will
understand one day he could be like i
get it i don't want to go
everyone seems to be on his side now but
she hasn't had her turn to talk and now
like everyone's waiting for her turn
what's she going to say what did johnny
do i want to know what job when two
people that get awards for lying
you can't trust a lot of them go to
court yeah that's hard it's a
performance maybe pay these people
millions of dollars to hoodwink us yes
and now we're going to
take a look
yeah like i don't think actors should be
allowed to testify in court right i
think it's mental that court is on telly
anyway but then when the thing that's in
court is actual movie style she's like
wow this guy's good at being in corny
well yeah he's been on telly since he's
like 19 years old i'm not suggesting
that johnny depp is in any way
performing i'm saying that the idea of
spectacle that turning justice and
people's private life into spectacle is
extraordinary because all of you have
had relationships all of you have had
your heart broken all of you have done
things in relationships that you regret
and had things done to you in
relationships that you regret hopefully
outside the realm of criminality but
nonetheless it's difficult to imagine
that turned into entertainment i'm
watching this trial like it's a
cautionary tale
it's a cautionary tale about believing
in [ __ ]
call like forming a narrative in your
head like we're rebels together we're
gonna yeah you know it's that's what i
felt like about anthony bourdain and his
relationship too that crazy woman
but
and then
you're seeing it all play out in court
like you've seen all the crazy come out
you know do you know the fact that like
he talked about her [ __ ] in his bed
yeah yeah it's great
it's so hot it's do you think no no no
right it's a real real problem
hard to forget it's a real problem
that's hard to forget but
she said that she used this specific
makeup to cover all of her bruises that
johnny gave her which is not true
specific makeup and that specific well
the problem is it was a specific makeup
it turns out that the company didn't
even make that makeup at the time that
she was claiming she was using it oh wow
you know what i believe is you shouldn't
put somebody's name out there until
you know 100 tried and convicted they
they definitely did that [ __ ] and then
if they did tar and feather them but to
do that to somebody
um
and also to give that weapon to somebody
that they can just [ __ ] say that
and blackmail you with that and and
really destroy your reputation
um
i don't know is is [ __ ] reprehensible
so there's another thing that isn't
really funny
you know
you know
it's like all those duke lacrosse
players
this [ __ ] they just [ __ ] faces all
over the [ __ ]
and you know to this day despite the
fact that they were totally vindicated
despite the fact that there was the 30
for 30 talking about how bad they got
railroaded despite all of that
you know that's still going to affect
their lives you know there's still going
to be somebody going uh yeah but you
know something happened you know
somebody when they get mad and they got
nothing else to say they're gonna call
him a rapist or something like that you
[ __ ] know that they're gonna and when
you hear all the [ __ ] that they did each
other sitting in the bed putting out
cigarettes on each other yeah what was
the straw that broke the camera's back
what made them say enough already
when they took away pirates of the
caribbean really i think if his career
is never affected
[ __ ] up relationship right now
yeah
why you have to tell people why you have
to tell people like we was having fun i
chopped my finger off you chopped it off
it is what it is he lost a piece of his
finger i saw that that i saw but i
couldn't tell whether she chopped it off
or he did there's rumors from everybody
you don't know with either these
[ __ ] they both lying their
asses off but still it's like [ __ ] you
just chop a piece of your finger off
apparently she threw a bottle at him
which chopped it off or maybe he did it
they don't even know the point is
they're both lunatics
but um it's just crazy to see like lies
on this level like this girl is this
girl's next level she wrote an op-ed
about him
that's the crate like it's not like it's
not like he was out here starting it
she wrote the op-ed she said all these
crazy things you know why because she
knows that whoever is the first person
with the narrative usually wins well and
that's just and that's true
she destroyed his career it's over
and now johnny got all of this other
stuff to go back and get amber this is
what i wish would happen i wish that
nobody would make any would jump to any
conclusions until all of this stuff
really plays out in court because if
they would have just waited and let
johnny depp and amber heard play out in
court then they could make a real
rational decision on what to do with
this person's career now do you put
things on hold cool
but just to like [ __ ] them get rid of
this get rid of that cancel this cancel
that that's not that's not what's up man
that [ __ ] play out in court you know i
used to be in hollywood i met johnny at
one time i met amber heard one time i
don't know either of these people very
well at all what i know though about the
culture of celebrity is people when they
go to court they'll be advised on how to
look and what to wear and how they're
being continually observed doesn't it
seem weird to you that justice which is
a sort of sacred idea because what
justice suggests is there is something
that is objectively and actually right
like that there is something that you
can say that's right that's wrong if you
look at justice in myth like king
solomon and the sword of damocles the
idea that wisdom can lead you to justice
that there is a right thing to do the
maharishi says do what you know to be
right don't do what you know to be wrong
think about your own life that takes
care of about 99 of everything there's
this small marginal area where you don't
know what's right this case is in that
area because if johnny depp is a violent
person that's bad if amber heard is
lying that's bad but have you ever been
in a relationship do you know how
complicated it gets in there when you're
like with a person that you love or that
you used to love and how baffling and
how difficult it gets and the places
that you go to and the fact that you
know that you're not perfect and it's
impossible to be perfect and you love
someone and hate someone imagine having
that played out on this kind of scale
because ultimately johnny depp is just
some bloke who's good at acting or when
you put a camera on it's sort of
exciting and interesting similarly amber
just a person just a human being that's
found themselves in a particular
situation it's a cautionary tale for
people that were thinking that it's
worth it to date a crazy girl because
she's great in bed
no this is my thing though how great is
she in bed that she can [ __ ]
in your bed she can rip your [ __ ]
index finger off and
she must she must be a real tomcat in
this act dude i think he's probably a
really nice guy and he
had great moments with her and he keeps
going back to those great moments
and thinking they can get past all this
craziness
because johnny i don't know johnny well
i've talked to him before but i know of
his career and i know of his love of
hunter thompson and he's close with uh
stan stanhope yeah very close and that's
how i know him how i've met
doing
available
he probably likes doing things he
shouldn't do like he probably likes
driving fast
he's probably an animal in in some ways
like he just loves like chaos and i
think that's one of the the reasons why
he loved hunter thompson he loved a
brilliant man who loved chaos and that's
what hunter was amber heard said the
same [ __ ] she goes i didn't punch you i
hit you
yo
he's like what are you talking about
like
that went over everybody's head no no no
no people are starting to realize that
she's a witch
but what are they going to do about it
men can't do that is what i'm saying and
listen we all know that double standards
exist but that is the reason why there's
so much chaos where there's a lack of
consistency yeah there will be chaos
yeah we need consistency all across and
where there's no accountability for
these [ __ ] accusations it's like
what do you think you need to be
punished for this [ __ ] and there's
nothing
that's what i mean when i say you know i
don't know what it means for people not
to agree also a woman to clarify he's
not perfect either like the dude is a
drug addict he's he's an alcoholic like
he's probably done foul [ __ ] like it's
fair to say they were both abusive to
each other they're both abusive so he's
not he let's not act like he's some
innocent [ __ ] but like she's
acting like she's completely innocent
she put crazy lies on this dude was
super foul to him and destroyed his
[ __ ] career like she didn't have no
career this [ __ ] was one of the
biggest superstars in history
and
goddamn genealogy it feels like a
performance always but yeah they have to
find people who don't know who they are
right or else gonna be so where is the
trial like in the appalachian mountains
if i'm in westeros
i'm not gonna date a really good actor
did you just call amber herder goldtech
no uh you know what i mean yeah i think
you meant amber i didn't this is a trial
with a jury which means mr depp gets to
appear for the first time in person
slick and he hopes persuasive this is a
good opportunity for looking at
mainstream media the use of the word
slick that's a choice slick suggests
manipulative oil slick think of the
connotations that come up for the word
slick sound like in he hopes persuasive
so there's certainly a judgment in the
editorial here what we're trying to do
on this channel is allow you to make
your judgment or participate in your
judgment with you or recognize the
futility even of making a judgment
because it's all just life isn't it
johnny depp is a human being amber heard
as a human being human beings make
mistakes what moral framework are we
going to operate within so we can deal
with the fact that human beings aren't
perfect is it that we're going to sort
of all pretend that we're individually
perfect and then just wait for someone
else to make you say aha mistake and
luckily you're a person i didn't like
anyway amber heard [ __ ] in johnny depp's
bed i was like yo maybe he's into that
yeah
he showed up late to her [ __ ]
birthday party she took a fat [ __ ] and
he was [ __ ] with that i [ __ ] with that
right though i [ __ ] with that don't be
like [ __ ] with that [ __ ] no don't do
that you can't be late for my birthday
party you my husband
for real for real i respect it yeah yeah
exactly i respect that [ __ ] exactly
yeah yeah
yeah
i
say what your wife don't show up to your
birthday party what do you do [ __ ]
exactly in the bag
[Laughter]
she's a crazy girl that girl's
absolutely she's out of her mind tell us
the worst fight you had in your opinion
miss heard called me an [ __ ]
um
because i didn't include her in
tickets
for a comedy show
we both wanted to go to kyle dunnigan
best comedian
living or or dead but i said if you want
to see him here's his website i wrote it
in blood
on our bathroom wall
with all the towns he's going to be in
coming up and that's what we're looking
at here
uh
yes
i want to go to the show kyle
dunnigan.com how do you spell that
respect amber heard that so we got free
amber then
yo free amber but free johnny too it
sucks
[Laughter]
free amber and johnny's movies
i think johnny should be able to act
again yeah real talk is like how are you
going to judge him if you ain't got your
dick sucked by her yet
it's mad people like listening to her
story
it's like sometimes
she'll suck your dick yep and i mean
this cuz i've heard this from people
she'll suck your dick
and you start going like i don't even
need that piece of my finger fam i'm on
team jeff for life you hear me yeah me
too team depp yeah man i mean i wish you
wouldn't wear uh eyeliner but yeah
and a little too many scarves right
right
he give a [ __ ] here's my thing without
giving a [ __ ] anymore yeah i don't he
can do no wrong in my book i'm a johnny
depp fan
[Music]
you